the sanderson sisters are back sisters
we have been gone
300 years well winnie how time flies
when you're dead
here's bette midler sarah jessica parker
and kathy najimi and the first official
look of the sanderson sisters back
together for hocus pocus 2. disney plus
debuted the first glimpse of the sequel
for the 1993 halloween classic as part
of disney plus day on twitter the photo
features the ladies reunited in their
original witchy attire as mary winifred
and sarah sanderson that shared her
excitement posting the same pick on
instagram with the caption sistas tis
time in addition to the new image of the
stars disney plus also announced the
film will premiere in fall 2022. aren't
you broad's a little old to be
trick-or-treating
we'll be younger in the morning now what
does hocus pocus 2 have in store for
fans of the original well the sequel
picks up 29 years since someone lit the
black flame candle and the three young
women who accidentally bring back the
sisters to modern day salem must then
figure out how to stop the witches from
wreaking havoc on the world does that
sound familiar we must find the book
brew the potion and suck the lies out of
the children of salem before sunrise
co-starring alongside the og sanderson
sisters will be some new faces including
whitney peak troy gutierrez and ted
lasso star hannah waddingham also part
of the cast is tony hale who recently
told et how excited he was to be joining
the franchise i mean that's a halloween
cult movie you know it's so it feels
really cool to be a part of it i also
worked with kathy on veep because she
was mike mcclintock's wife
and then my first gig in new york was
sex in the city i was like a little
guest star so i've i've never met sarah
but it's like so it's really cool to
work with these women you know um
[Music]
you